recently a study conducted by arizona
christian university was published
george barna the university's cultural
research center's director led the
research to call the results of this
research striking would be a significant
understatement it's hard to come up with
one single word to describe this so
we'll just get into it here's the
summary from an article in newsweek it
says 30 percent of millennials identify
as lgbtq according to a soon to be
released study that's based on
scientific polling data among christians
the numbers were lower but only slightly
with just under 30 percent of millennial
christians identifying as lgbtq the
portion of the population that described
itself as gay has varied over the years
from 10 percent based on research by
alfred kinsey widely promoted and widely
promoted by the national gay task force
in 1977 to less than six percent
in a recent gallup poll
now a couple of notes about that before
we look at these results more closely uh
you may recall from our discussion of
alfred kinsey a couple months ago that
the ten percent figure was completely
bogus at the time
kinsey wanted there to be a large
portion of homosexuals in the country he
wanted to create a society where
heterosexuality was but one mode of
sexuality among an array of equal
options
and so he falsified his research to kind
of get the ball rolling so to speak he
surveyed male prostitutes sex offenders
men in prison
carefully choosing from
non-representative samples of the
population and then extrapolated
all kinds of conclusions about male
sexuality based on that the prevalence
of homosexuality was the least of what
he falsely concluded now this is
relevant because it shows how there's
been a very real plot
a plan
yes if you like a conspiracy to
fundamentally change human sexuality
it was set in motion by degenerate
quacks like alfred kinsey and john money
and now we're seeing uh the fruits of
their label labor so a little more from
newsweek it says the poll looked at
so-called millennials defined as someone
born from 1984 to 2002
about 78 million individuals
representing a quarter of u.s population
among millennials 30 percent identifies
lgbt lgbtq more than three times that of
the rest of the adult population
and when the researchers broke out uh
the youngest of the group ages 18 to 24
which is really gen z
they found 39
call themselves lgbtq
okay so we're talking
40 nearly 40 percent identifying as lgbt
now if this is true
if these numbers are anywhere close to
accurate
then we are witnessing not even just a
seismic shift in human sexuality but a
full-on transformation unlike anything
the world has ever seen before
many people though on both sides of the
ideological divide for different reasons
don't want to believe or admit that such
a transformation is actually happening
so they have a few ways of trying to
deny or mitigate results like this on
the left
they'll say that this doesn't reflect a
change at all they'll claim that there
have always been this many lgbt people
in society but they just didn't feel
comfortable revealing themselves
until now
that's that's that's what they'll say
but this is not credible because older
generations have also been surveyed
in our current day and age
where everybody is very accepting and
tolerant and all of that older
generations are also surveyed and their
numbers are much much lower
so the left's theory kind of waves a
magic wand over millions of americans
and declares that you know they're all
closeted gays with no evidence at all
for such an assertion
also if we're looking at this from a
purely biological
and evolutionary perspective
it doesn't make any scientific sense
that 40 or 50 or more of a species would
be non-heterosexual
now
the left claims that homosexuality is
biological right
um
then if that's true
then a 40 or 50 figure simply could not
happen for evolutionary reasons
unless you want to argue that evolution
isn't true
keep in mind the left loves to claim
also that homosexual activity exists in
the animal kingdom right you hear this
all the time
well find me a species where nearly half
are homosexual
that doesn't exist it can't exist
because such a species would go extinct
so this theory doesn't work
but you'll have people on the right who
deny it as well they you know simply
because they don't want to believe that
the lgbt brainwashing of kids has really
been this tremendously successful
they just don't want to believe it
it's it's it's it's something that they
can't wrap their heads around and so
they say no there's no way and they'll
say the numbers here are wrong yet the
problem for them is that these results
are just the latest in a long line of
research
conducted both by right-leaning and
left-leaning organizations and they all
come to the same sort of conclusion
gallup as mentioned by newsweek they did
a major poll several months ago they
didn't find that 30 or 40 percent of gen
z identifies lgbt but they did find that
15 identified that way and another 5
had no opinion about their own sexuality
so that's 20 percent not identifying as
heterosexual
a smaller portion but still 10 times
their parents generation and 20 times
their grandparents generation
so whether it's 20 or 30 or 40 it's
almost splitting hairs
the point is that there is a trend here
a very dramatic trend
and it's a trend against spanning
generations which rules out the other
dismissive claim which you still hear
from some on the right that this is all
a fad right
lgbt identification for the kids today
it's like what um emo or goth was when i
was a kid
but we know it's not just a fed of that
sort because you find this trend against
spanning generations starting with my
grandparents going all the way down to
my kids generation
lgbt identification has risen by large
portions each step of the way until
today
we also know that it's not just a fad
because fads when we were kids were
treated like fads
adults would tell you you know if you
were a goth
an adult would say to you this is a fad
you're going to look back on this and be
embarrassed
what they didn't say to the goth kid is
this is your truest identity you should
define yourself by your gothness
this is the most important thing about
you here i made you this flag march
through the street with it let everybody
know
this is who you are and will always be
if adults had said that then there would
be there'd still be a lot of people in
my generation today walking around with
dyed hair and makeup
well in fact there are a lot of people
in my generation walking around that way
but not because they identify as goth
and that's the point
so if this is not a fad which it isn't
and if it is not a natural biological
occurrence
which is only today finding its true
expression which it also isn't
then what's going on
well what's going on is social contagion
a kind of mass hysteria a group
hallucination in effect
but one that is constructed
fabricated
okay this is all intentional
it is social engineering on a scale and
at a level previously unknown to mankind
we've seen brainwashing before but never
like this
and never has it started so young
so this seems relevant a video that went
viral uh this week like a million other
videos of this type
we've got again
a very young boy four years old in this
case
paraded on camera
in the female alter ego that his mother
has imposed on him and she's very proud
of it
let's listen to that
to your face ty
makeup you put makeup on it
how old are you
seven
no how old are you
seven no four nine seven are you a boy
or a girl a guy a girl
were you born a girl
were you born a girl
when you were a baby were you a girl yes
are you in a boy's body though
yes yeah
okay tell tick tock bye
bye
[Music]
yeah who who bought him that makeup this
is his choice right who bought him the
uh the little pink dress there
quite an interesting clip once you can
get past the visceral revulsion
you notice the incoherent arbitrary line
the mother draws she'll respect the boys
she'll she will respect the boy's
self-identification his alleged
self-identification as a girl
but not his self-identification is seven
years old and why not
age is more fluid and changing than sex
which doesn't change at all
age is also relative
i mean relative at least to what planet
you're on there there are planets in the
universe where that boy would actually
be seven years old
so why can't he identify as seven then
if he wants he says he's seven and the
mother has no problem saying no no no
you're not seven you're mistaken
about how old you are
because you're a little boy and you
don't know you don't understand how age
works
yet
she won't say that to the boy about his
biological sex
and notice how the boy who is uh
supposedly a girl now you can't see this
if you're just listening to the audio
but
they're outside and um and as he's
talking about the fact that he's girl
he's trying to climb on the wall
while while talking about how he's a
girl
now climbing on walls is a boy activity
i have two of them
that's what they do we have the wall
smudges to prove
it so this is a boy acting like a boy in
every in every way
it's just that he's been dressed this
way by his mother
and the boy isn't old enough to sort
through this incoherence and sadly he
may never be able to see it for what it
is even when he's older because his
brain is being rewired
his entire conception of himself is
being altered
his mother cannot make him a girl like
she wants but she can change him
drastically and permanently
and a version of this to some degree or
another
is happening to an entire generation
as it happened to much lesser degrees to
generations before them
you know we're worried about our kids
being indoctrinated into critical race
theory
and socialism
and becoming democrats
well sure we should be worried about
that
but none of that when it comes to the
indoctrination of kids none of that
comes anywhere close to this
to generations of kids
being completely
redefined their identities redefined
as we all sit back and watch
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content